everyone welcome to another Android
developer lab so thanks for joining us
we are running 3 minutes late but that's
okay hopefully that's been giving you
enough time to join so with that being
said let's get started with the news the
first bit of news is a really exciting
and we're really proud of it the Nexus 7
tablet has one gadget and tablet of the
year so that's really awesome really
fantastic we couldn't be prouder of the
Android engineering team as well as our
partners assist and other than being a
great tablet for consumers to use it's a
fantastic development tablet too so yeah
we're really we're really really happy
all right moving on to more developer
specific news we launched our trials for
subscriptions so now you get a period
where you can try the the subscription
app not just magazines but even app so
you can trial it for a little while
before the user has to commit to
purchasing it so this is a great way for
users to get a taste of the app before
they purchase it and we think it's going
to be a really beneficial for developers
the next thing is that with this week
has been a tablet week so well we said a
while last week and we certainly started
off with it and our European team as
well we published some some materials
this week so first was the blog the
Android developers blog and we talked
about building tablet quality tablet
apps it also had a link to this to our
developer portal called building quality
apps so on that building quality apps
there's actually three sections and one
of them specializes on tablets it is
actually like it has a checklist to say
well this is what makes a quality tablet
app so for those of you that are
building phone apps and not building
tablet apps now is the best time to get
in last week's ADL plus covered
fragments which are really a fundamental
piece of building
for phones and tablets so if you haven't
seen it already you should you should
definitely view last week's ADL Plus app
and then go along with this new
checklist that we've published next
slide please and over to you any good
okay hi guys so for today's talk we're
going to cover connectivity AP ice for
jellybeans and we're gonna announce
something really exciting at the end of
the presentation on connectivity API so
stay tuned so so what we're going to
look at is what our connectivity AP is
and what's you with jellybeans so
basically these are set up wireless AP
is and they enable devices to
communicate between each other so they
come they can communicate with the cloud
and that's about using your regular
Wi-Fi to connect to your servers on the
cloud in full data and they can also
talk to each other so some of these
technologies that are that can enable
this kind of communication or Wi-Fi
Bluetooth and Android Beam which is
built on top of NFC so and these are
existing it of since ICS we had android
game and then Wi-Fi and Bluetooth have
been much there much before so in terms
of what's new for jellybean we
introduced something called Wi-Fi direct
service discovery and network service
discovery end and these are the two
topics we will cover in detail with the
launch of ICS we introduced the Wi-Fi
direct which is a peer-to-peer
technology for connecting devices and we
jelly bean we've kind of introduced
services company along with the Wi-Fi so
so first look at what wife is like I
mentioned it it allows peers which is
two devices within their Wi-Fi range to
find and discover each other and once
they discover each other they perform
discovery they are able to connect and
then use sockets for transferring data
so and these can happens within and it's
kind of interesting because the Wi-Fi
range is as a much larger than the
Bluetooth range and also the connection
is high speed connection with Wi-Fi so
it is it's a very interesting
and fast way of connecting high-speed
connections between devices so which
brings us to the new API is in jelly
bean which is Wi-Fi service discovery so
with regular Wi-Fi direct which was
introduced in ICS you could connect to
devices and once you connect you first
performed discovery and once a discovery
is done you get the netbook details of
the other device which is the IP address
to correctly and then you connect to the
device once you connect to the device
your application sort of has to publish
the services available through the
application so if your device is a if
your app is a game multiplayer game so
only when the device was the other
device is able to connect to you you can
say hey I am I have multiplayer lobby
available and this is how you start
exchanging data so this this this wasn't
actually a very good user experience
that you have to connect to devices to
figure out what services are available
so that's where the Wi-Fi service
discovery comes in Wi-Fi direct service
is coming and it's a pre Association
discovery so you can actually find
services before establishing or
associating yourself to the AP which is
the access point so you can figure out
what services are available then if
you're really interested you can connect
your particular device which is hosting
that service or the app that is forcing
that service on the device so the
devices and this comes from Wi-Fi direct
itself the devices are not connected to
a network or don't have to be connected
to a network you do not have to have an
existing Wi-Fi network around a classic
locked-room based access point out the
devices can just connect to each other
whenever they're near the Wi-Fi range of
each other so which basically means
before they're assigned the IP address
of the network they they are able to
discover each other the discover the
services you and the device itself and
then if interested in the service
establish a connection so this actually
into a very better really improved user
experience so you browser sprinting
this is and five transfer services and
available nearby and then you can't go
device that you want so some of the gig
is nice or Wi-Fi p2p are okay some of
the key API is for Wi-Fi p2p are a sorry
if we've got a video feed from someone
ah are we getting some echo are we on
your head oh yeah just meet them all
right so some of the key API is
available from as part of the Wi-Fi p2p
services so its discovery API is our and
these are the objects listed there's a
Wi-Fi p2p service info which encapsulate
saw Wi-Fi p2p service which is and then
p2p handstand transfer here to here
which is Wi-Fi direct so there's a Wi-Fi
direct service info object which in
caplets a service which you want to
publish then there's a service request
so another two specializations of these
service requests and a service info one
is a DNS SD this is a DNS pay service
discovery and the other one is upnp and
this is a popular universal plug and
play protocol that you find in a lot of
media devices and DLNA compliant devices
and this is used this is kind of
specialized for meeting yeah
technologies like mentoring and
publishing streams of audio and video so
there's Anna specialization for DNS
space service and a plugin upnp based
service so now we gonna get a bit more
technical and we're going to see and
take a look at court and to see and some
code snippets to see how does this
actually work so the first thing you
want to do from device a which is the
first device that's interested in
connecting or is interested in being
part of a peer to peer exchange will
publish a service so before you can
actually connect to a service you need a
population service so you create a local
service shop Jake and
what do you do is you have an instance
name and a service fight so the instance
name is something really that your
application is so this could be test or
you know my chat or my printing service
and then there's a service type which is
a which is a standard name that's
followed and these lists of names are
registered with I na which is a body
that manages manages the service types
and so if you're publishing service
that's not already included as part of
ein a services you can register your
service type with the ine and body and
then use a service type so this would
typically be something like so for
example for chat service we use
something called presents and presence
is the name for a chat service so you
your service site will be present and
similarly there are names for printing
and for other network services so all
right so what we've seen is you're able
to create now a local service object and
then you register this local service
with the Wi-Fi p2p manager Wi-Fi p2p
manager is a system utility that it's a
framework class that's available to you
just like just like the connectivity
manager or the telephony manager you say
context or get system service and then
you say well if I mean manager and you
get a handle to be manager object so so
we've seen the part of where a device is
able to publish a service now on the
peer device which actually wants to use
the service or consume this service you
will create a service discovery request
and then you will go ahead and perform a
service discovery so first you have on
you create an instance she ate an object
that describes your request is basically
you have some fields that we will look
into and then you ask the Wi-Fi p2p
manager to form the discovery so when
you're implementing this in android
first thing is let's some of the
permissions you need a change Wi-Fi
state and access Wi-Fi a state
permission and also you need internet
permission it's not because we are going
to exchange
data over the Internet it's only because
we are going to use sockets to
communicate between devices ends we've
kind of the sockets maintenance function
is time two sockets usage so you would
require this permission as well in your
manifest so now now at a code level and
these are in these methods of code and
it's pretty easy to write this code just
to three lines per per operation that
you want to perform in so the first
thing we look at is appear adding a
local service so here's the service
class that we talked about earlier as a
key API this is Wi-Fi p2p dns service
info and you just use a static
initializer on that same new instance
and the two things that you are looking
at the parameters there are the other
ones are the instance lame and the
service type so the instance name is our
instance of the service which is
underscore test here and because it's a
kind of track service so we are using a
standard name for the chat service and
notice the naming convention here this
is followed for all the services type
for all in DNS based services which
underscore so its type underscore the
protocol is going to follow over the
network so the third thing is really
interesting it's a record and this is a
DNX dns text recorded and this is also
pretty much standard and this carries
additional metadata about your service
so for example if it's a chat service
and along with saying that you have a
chat service you also want to say that
as a user I am available to chat at this
point of time or i am busy and i cannot
check so the service is available but
you are busy and you cannot respond to
chat messages so the next extra guard is
kind of a key value thing and this is
where you can publish an additional
metadata about your service so and you
can keep publishing these records which
these regards can change over time so
your service is published and it's
available as a chart service and then
you can keep pushing pls text icon
saying i'm available at this point of
time I'm not available and busy
so once once you've done that we add the
local service to and the end manager
object that you see here is the Wi-Fi
p2p manager and then you add this local
service and there is a call back many
many operations are almost all
operations of Wi-Fi p2p direct and DNS
network service discovery are
asynchronous and your ways register a
callback for success or failure and so
this is kind of a standard template for
all operations of network for all
operations of service discovery so we
instituted a service info object which
had our instance name and service type
and a DNS texture card and so once we've
created that we go ahead and say in my
manager or not add local service and as
soon as you do that your service is
published over the Wi-Fi p2p network
Wi-Fi network and in case there is an
Ender you can have that error ensure
procreate messages to be user so I like
it said all the operations are
asynchronous so every time you perform
an operation you're going to pass a call
back or register for action listener
like a success failure and because it's
asynchronous in nature you don't have to
worry about where you are placing this
call you can be your main preppy and the
line network all is always off the main
threat so you don't have to worry about
the lightning asynchronous async task
and then placing these calls where
they're inherently its appearance so all
right we've not published the service
those two lines of code on so the other
device the other peer that's interested
in consuming ish and where your app is
running if it wants to discover the
nearby service and connect to it it
first needs to create a DNS as the
service response listener so which
basically is a call back where has one
method which is on DNS SB service
available and we talked about upnp and
these this is the same kind of mechanism
that you fall around for you ENT so when
there's a UPS
always available you will see on begin p
service available with a upnp service
response display so this is a call back
the the method on the anonymous
implementation there is called when the
services when the framework is available
to discover a service when they have
great device discovers a service it's
going to give you a call back there so
first thing you do is you instantiate a
service response listener and you send
it in the manager so you say Wi-Fi p2p
manager here is my services spawn
response listener in cancer is a service
call me back so we've said our response
listener and then what we want to do is
actually create a service request and
this works again if you remember one of
the key api's so you will say use the
Wi-Fi p2p service request object to get
a new instance again a static
initializer there and once you are able
to get a service request you add the
service request to the Wi-Fi PT manager
and again there's a asynchronous
fallback such as failure once this is
done you actually go ahead and perform
discovery by saying manager or discover
services and then this is where the
framework actually starts discovering
your services you've already registered
of this fastener you've given yourself
sequest and now the framework is able to
perform discovery and if it finds
something it's able to call back on your
interfaces so so once the service is DN
SSD services available you will also
receive a Wi-Fi p2p device object along
with it this is a basically a structure
that has details about the pier IP and
the other connection will be in it in
details and this is when you can
actually go ahead and form a network
connection so you're able to query the
the Wi-Fi p2p manager for nearby
services and suppose you find the
service or maybe a printing service or
maybe or chat service that you want to
connect to this at this point of time
which is after performing discovery and
the framework gives you a call back on
the interface you can now say you cannot
see the connection details and go ahead
and
from connect to the other device and
this basically means initiating an
access point Association and so that
once once this is done you're on the
same network now you get assigned IP
addresses on the same network the same
Wi-Fi p2p network and once this is done
you're able to open sockets because
you're the same network now you can open
tcp socket and start exchanging data
which is your app data so what the
framework is really giving you is a
mechanism is sort of a framework for
publishing your services and consuming
other service discovering and consuming
other services so this was this was
completely Wi-Fi p2p which is based on a
Wi-Fi p2p network so the condition there
was there doesn't have to be an existing
network two devices capable of Wi-Fi p2p
direct will find each other discover the
services and care and the other thing is
the other API that we produced network
service discovery and this is basically
based on the fact that you're already
part of the network that you want to
join and discover services and you're
connected to the network organ and in
this network you wanna discover services
in your which are available in your
local network so this is pretty similar
to bonjour if you work with pancho on
the apple systems are there are other
zeroconf networking solutions available
on linux and other platforms and this is
basically bringing the same dns face
multicast dns based service discovery to
android and we we call it network
service discovery alright and like I
mentioned it's different from Wi-Fi
direct because Wi-Fi direct immediately
you need a network and this is when
you're actually locked into a local
network so if you bring your suppose you
bring your device to your work place and
you connect to your corporate Internet
your internet and you have some printers
available and you want to print maybe
some document that's some PDF on yahoo
from your mobile phone and if the and
many other printers understand what is a
network service discovery and multicast
dns so
you can discover these printing services
available and go ahead and print after
you are able to make a correction and
again file sharing is one of the big
things on a local network and
multiplayer gaming in the multiplayer
gaming swim useful and can really
benefit from technologies like Wi-Fi p2p
direct and network service discovery so
you're going into technical details of
how it works in this case you will
create something called a registration
listener and this is this is the device
that's publishing a service this may
already be an existing device on the
network or it may be an Android device
device which is offering maybe a
multiplayer gaming and are a chance
illness and this is how it will go ahead
and publish its service so you create
something called a registration mr. in
in terms of DNS based networks of this
discovery we call it registration
instead of saying publishing a service
on the networks of naming convention is
falling here see you register your
servers on the network by creating a
callback for registration listener and
then you again have the same kind of
details you have the instance name of
the service of the type and the service
type is compliant with I na and so here
is some code basically it's again a call
back an anonymous implementation of
registration listener which has some
standard methods which is your service
has been registered on service
registered on registration fail on
service unregistered and on
unregistering fail so the framework is
going to call any of these methods when
depending on what really happened with
your request and so you can listen to
these notifications and you know show
the proper you I go ahead with actually
connecting two devices so once you've
created registration listener what you
want to create is in description for
your service and again we use something
called nsp service info the process
similar to
looked at earlier as Wi-Fi p2p service
and for CBN SDS ocean for here we said
the service name the service type and
the network port it's going to run on
because we already in the network we can
specify what what my soul's will run off
and you get a handle to n SP managers
same as Wi-Fi p2p direct and other
system services you say contact start
Kent system service and get a hundred do
NSD manager and once you get the manager
handle you created the registration mr.
you can say register my cell is here is
link for this service and here its
registration listener which is the car
back we're into where the framework
would call you back and depending on
what really goes on the get request so
with this value but the study a server
so as you can see it's just two three
lines of code per per operation and it's
pretty easy to implement so now you've
now you've register your service on the
network on a network a DNS Space Network
nsp service you've registered and now
you want to discover those services so
what really happens behind the scene is
multicast DNS technologies involved here
and you're listening to the network
broadcast and using some framework api's
you can filter out what services you
want to consume what do not want to cut
you and again it's asynchronous API just
like Wi-Fi p2p direct all the operations
are performed of the main threats so you
can make your call anywhere so just like
when station listener when you're
discovering service if you create
something like discovery listener and
this will be used to initiate so is this
coming again as you would have guessed
it's a it's a callback which the
framework is coming used to call you
back on when it's able to find something
for you so this on discovery started the
framework has started this coming
services again time to update your UI
turned a user that we are locating
service you're finding services of
answer is found you get the fall back
with v service info what we need that
service is and this is where you can
perform frequent if you're not
interested in connecting to the service
you can filter on the service and there
are some other callbacks on when the
service is lost
both the other device goes out of
network or goes down get the service not
when discovery is sort of an ongoing
process I want to kick it off so you can
actually request a finger to stop
discovering and that's when you get the
call back on this coming stop and some
other call backs on something fail this
family you'll stop his family fare you
get a couple of other callbacks so now
now we've created a discovery listener
and what the mains now is to request
discovery so you say NSD manager brought
this cover services this here is my
discovery Lister and you get the call
box with weather framework has an update
for you which is its able to perform
discovery and find some service or it
failed it gives you a call back on your
fiscal minister so I'm good if you're
the framework is able to find your
service what you do and this is on the
call back on service form when it's able
to do that you instantiate something
called a resolve listener which is to
find Network details of the pier so that
you can connect so the resolve listener
will have callbacks again on the server
when the framework is able to resolve
the service for you which is all VIP for
you and then you call the framework once
you create the resolve listener in
provide an implementation you call an SP
manager or a salt service and that's it
you you get the IP details of the device
or the network machine that's publishing
a service and it's time for you now to
connect and the connection is here
basically sockets like we discussed
earlier you're on a network and if the
services DCP base you played a TCP
socket or Datagram so to summarize a
we've looked at two nuclea p eyes which
we like to call connectivity api's and
these are Wi-Fi p2p service discovery
and Wi-Fi direct services from me and
network service discovery so y Wi-Fi p2p
service discovery protocol has a DNS and
support for upnp implementation a the
the thing about your PMP now is that
it's closely tied up with the associated
with the DLNA protocol that's used
between many devices you know your your
HD televisions your Playstations your
xboxes you're a lot of media DVD players
blu-ray players they're using a DLNA
protocol to share and scheme media so
one device is kind of acting as a
screening device that scheming the media
the other sort of acts as a renderer and
is able to show what the other devices
screaming and this is all this is well
working on top of BL NN upnp protocols
so Wi-Fi p2p so is just calmly of why do
the ability to connect and publish these
services you could be the media and
there are you put sure media and then
there is network service discovery which
would have ad which is sort of zeroconf
networking thing that's sort of similar
to Bonjour and you're able to find ENS
pace services on the network soon and
with this you can find services when
you're not connected to a network using
Wi-Fi p2p direct and when you are
connected to network using network
service discovery so this kind of brings
us to the end of the presentation here
thanks honey earth so I nirads obviously
covered a lot of things today about you
know all the sort of options that you
have when it comes to connectivity on
Android and we think that the the
capability is great and what we'd like
to see is more people use it and sort of
impress us to show us how you know what
are the creative things you can come up
with so today we'd like to announce
something new that we're we're doing
we're calling it a do plus experiments
and we're going to launch our first
experiment today so what what a do plus
experiments is is it's a plus page that
you should go ahead and circle and this
announcement that we're just doing right
now we will be making the same
announcement on the plus page as well so
a do plus experiment is a way for you to
get involved with with the things that
we present and today we're launching our
first experiment which based on the
connectivity API is that that are you
with this presented for us so the goal
is very simple actually you're tasked
with building a cool app this is
obviously optional for you to whether
you want to get involved or not but we
think this is a really great way to
showcase your talents to the rest of the
developer community so build a cool app
come up with some great concept using
these connectivity api's and then what
you should do is share that APK with the
plus ADL experiments page so you know
just send us a link to the APK a
download link whether it's Google Drive
or Dropbox or any other sort of service
that you may use and in when you share
it with us tell us what the app is and
more importantly how to use it and tell
us what makes it special you can you you
can choose to share the source code if
you want whether if you're using like a
github repository or otherwise google
code for example and yeah we'll take a
look and so what we're kind of doing and
this is this program in itself is quite
an experiment where we do launching it
for the first time so it's a way for you
to showcase your talents it's a way to
sort of energized the community and by
all means you you can collaborate so
send us these submissions we've kind of
put a date a cutoff date of the 30th of
October as we get the until free to send
it before then as we get submissions
we're going to go through them and after
that cut off the incentive for you is
with you know we'll pick a handful that
we think are really really nice and we
will highlight these apps you know so
it'll drive some downloads to you but
more importantly we'd like to invite you
to to a future ADL plus so you can tell
us how you built the app what challenges
you had and have other people ask
questions as well so try and utilize
these these topics that were presenting
and yeah that's that's a deal plus
experiments I need is there anything you
want to add to that up just for this
specific
topic if you're if you want to learn
more there is an Android cleaning
available called connecting devices
wirelessly and this can help you with
your first experiment so go ahead and
take a look it's published on our
developer site so hopefully this means
that people are going to start
submitting apps you know some work that
they're doing and these things don't
need to be complete apps that i need to
you know be published necessarily if
they're published on play that's great
but these can be just you know tech demo
is effectively where you're showcasing
something cool that you're doing you
know we we love this developer community
and where we're trying to see how we can
get you more involved in the ideal plus
so ADL experiments we really hope you
are you engage because it means that if
you find this sort of thing useful then
we'll do more of these experiments in
the future so we're going to talk about
this or mention ADL experiments every
week up until that code cut off and then
you know future radio plus we'll we'll
try and showcase some of these apps and
and see if we can bring the developers
on as well so with that we shall move on
to QA so we have one person that's live
on the Hangout at the moment who hasn't
said anything but do you want to did you
have any questions to ask before we
shift to the moderator page doesn't look
like it that's okay so we have a couple
of questions on moderator I'll read out
the first one i get errors from ICS
users with map activity an exception
which is basically a no class definition
exception found android security that
message digest if I google the error
people say that it's a problem because
an old version of map API is on the
device how do I solve the problem the
target SDK is version 16 so I had a look
at this and there seems to be very
there's a handful of cases where this
has sort of been reported on stack
overflow
I wanted to ask you you said ICS users
but on those Stack Overflow threads
there were people with ice cream
sandwich devices that were saying hey
this this works fine for me I don't have
I don't have problems with this APK so i
must admit this is an issue that i
haven't heard of before i'd love to get
down to the bottom of it so this is
mackin from Sweden and I apologize if
I've messed up the pronunciation but um
please reach out to me on on google+ and
let's see if we can diagnose it further
I'm interested in knowing where there's
the devices that you were testing on our
you know is there something special
about them are they normal ice cream
sandwich devices that you buy from a
from a shop or from your telco or are
they running custom roms is there a
chance that these devices don't have the
Google services on them because they're
you know they're running a custom
version of the platform or something
along those lines and more importantly
are all of you saying every single Ice
Cream Sandwich device is struggling to
run this this APK so please reach out to
me I'd love to follow up further only
did you want to add anything to that uh
no I think just give us some more info
and you will be able to help you yeah we
should definitely try and get to the
bottom of this all right so our next
question I need to Android development
and don't know how to design and develop
any app could you please give me some
references from where I can learn about
the environment setup and app
development thanks so this is Harshad
from Mumbai India look the best place to
start is developing on android com
there's a section called develop and
there's a getting started guide there it
shows you how to download the SDK how to
set it up and he even has some sample
apps that you that it helps you sort of
build that there's tutorials there so
developer.android.com it's the place
where you'll find all of our tools it's
where you'll find all of our
documentation if you have any sort of
specific questions you should definitely
be posting to stack overflow using the
android tag and you
have a huge community of Android
developers that will be just ready and
willing to help you but the important
thing is that your question is very
broad you're saying hey look I don't
know how to design or develop any app
it's it's really important to just sort
of get your hands dirty start playing
with the tutorial start writing sample
apps and in the in the beginning it may
be hard you may feel like hey this is
not a very high quality app that's okay
that's how you learn and that's really
the focus of it next question can i
retrieve data from the google maps api
so i can use it for my location based
services service application that I'm
developing this is pretty from
philippines I know do you want to take
this fun yes so the API that's available
is called Google Places API and that's
what you would probably like to use with
your location based services available
you can use this API it's a rest-based
API and there is a token unique so what
you need to do is go to your developer
console which is code.google.com / AP I
/ console this is where you create a
project where whenever you're trying to
use any of the guys here so there you
need to enable Google Places API and I
think there is some quota that's
available to you free and then you need
to pay beyond a certain number of
requests so if you just try not you
could probably try for free and there is
google and the Google Places API is
there and if you go to a developer
website developers.google.com you can
look up the service reference and all
the API reference and the different
clients available to you we do have a
Java fine with your Java client library
and yes you can pretty much useless the
places API and if I remember correctly I
think reto Meier one of her advocates
you probably know him he published a
tutorial on location based services and
he also shared the sample source code so
if you just look up the history of the
archives of Android block you would
probably find this tutorial and he is
using your places API there to fetch
places of interest foreign location
based service basically allow users to
check in where they want so go ahead and
then there's a lot of sample a complete
application that you stripped in there
so you'll find a lot of sample code
there on how to use or consume yourself
yet cool thank you so final question why
can't the google play store send back
the install referrals back either at the
Google Play Developer console or through
an API currently the in device install
referral process is broken we have big
product marketing plans around that
feature that's from gopinath in
Bangalore India do you want to do want
to take this one as well I knew it yeah
so I don't really know if it's not
available if it's not available I would
say that this is a feature request we
can take up to our team so just hang on
to your big product marketing class
before it's released and and I'm not
even sure if it's going to be at least
Im we will just take your feedback to
our product in and see how they want to
prioritize this yes yeah I was under the
impression that something that
definitely we do support reference but I
think the key thing here might be the in
the question he mentions about the in
device experience or on device i think
is what it meant that the referral
process might be broken because if you
do oh by the way i'm i'm pretty sure we
that that process works pretty well and
i'd be surprised if if it didn't
translate well to the device so yeah let
us let us look that up for you and run
that past our team and see if we can get
a response so please do reach out to
either any other than myself and now
trying we're going to look up the answer
anyway but there's no way for us to
contact you directly here so yeah we'll
do that just so now this question I
think is a fairly new question it wasn't
there a couple of hours ago so we
haven't had that the opportunity to have
an answer ready for this one all right
well I haven't seen any
shins on any further questions on
moderator is are there any questions on
the the thread where we've hosted this
young Felix you just check the we're
just checking the thread not that
doesn't seem to me all right well thank
you for joining us look we mentioned
before that that you're announcing
something and it was a deal experiments
it's really for developers to get their
hands dirty with this stuff it's so we
hope that's useful for you it's exciting
for us because it it get we get to see
some of the creativity that developers
come up with when using these these new
API so thanks I knew it for presenting
connectivity and thanks to all of you
for tuning in so that's our finding off
for this week we'll catch you next week
see this see you later